c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
sont les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir la région de ménaka au mali
dans le viseur des djihadistes plusieurs
dizaines de civils et combattants
maliens du msa mouvement pour le salut
de l'azawad ont été tués nous écouterons
dès le début de ce journal moussa à
gaschard attoumane secrétaire général du
msa et porte parole du cadre stratégique
permanent
l'alertent de l'onu son secrétaire
général met en garde contre la crise
alimentaire qui va frapper les pays les
plus pauvres conséquence directe de la
guerre en ukraine un plus gros pour un
des plus gros producteurs de blé dans le
monde nous écouterons antonio intéressés
nous nous intéresserons au cas de la
tunisie dans cette édition la
présidentielle au kenya elle se tiendra
dans cinq mois mais les candidats
commencent à se déclarer l'une des
surprises du scrutin l'alliance entre le
président sortant ou kenyatta et son
plus grand rival raila odinga
les kenyans se passionne déjà pour ce
scrutin reportage à suivre
ça s'est passé à tama là tu es in sinan
de localité malienne située dans la
région de ménaka non loin de la
frontière avec le niger plusieurs
dizaines de morts parmi les civils et
les combattants du msa le mouvement pour
le salut de l'azawad ils ont été ciblés
à par des djihadistes selon le msa les
assaillants sont des membres de l'état
islamique au grand sahara un groupe
affilié au groupe etat islamique la
situation dans la région est inquiétante
écouter et moussa hague achard attoumane
secrétaire général du rsa et porte
parole du cadre stratégique permanent il
répondait aux questions de notre
correspondante à bamako à une fleur
l'espion je tiens quand même à préciser
que ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on
sent pas les populations civiles le long
de cette frontière est à illescas de
ouatagouna dans les cercles sont beaux
ils étaient six et ils les pays d armor
garde à illies la zone dite il ya dans
toutes ces zones là malheureusement
c'est toujours la même organisation qui
a massacré sans distinction des
populations civiles gila que la
particularité à terme aller de c1 qu'ils
ont se sont opposés à une faute une
farouche résistance de la msa qui
étaient présents la 28e régate ya et
d'autres mouvements à allier aussi qui
se sont joués à nous a par la suite et
grâce à notre intervention nous avons
quand même pu sauver la vie à des
milliers de civils qui est là et cette
situation aussi a provoqué un
déplacement massif de populations qui
étaient dans le village des tablettes
pour aller un peu plus au nord vers vers
le cercle dîner 4 mai dans la zone d une
finale n'est la drôme boucane bonne
partie de la population soit encore s'il
place même si la paire quand même règne
dans cette zone là il tient aussi à
remercier les forces de défense et de
sécurité maliennes pour la première fois
qu'ils ont pu quand même à intervenir
avec un hélicoptère qui a pu faire des
phrases notamment au side in china et
nous étions allés besoin le fait que
l'armée viennent annoncer coup je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'on doit qui
doit être s'allier en cours chez
président tient à préciser que sur le
terrain il ya que les mouvements qui
sont présents l'armée est à ménaka même
si elle à intervenir par les herbes mais
notre souhait c'est que bien évidemment
l'armée s'est déployée dans ces zones là
sinon autrement on a beau fournir des
efforts au mali au niger les mêmes
efforts ne sont pas sur place
burkina ou dans d'autres zones ça va
être extrêmement difficile et c'est ce
qui rend la tâche facile à cette
organisation qui se permet de massacrer
les populations dans la zone des trois
frontières et je profite de votre
antenne aussi pour solliciter non
seulement l'appui des autorités mais
aussi de toutes les organisations
internationales pour venir en urgence à
l'aide des ses populations parce que
malheureusement lors de ces attaques là
il ya des femmes et des enfants aussi
qui ont été touchés et aujourd'hui
toutes ces formulations dans des
difficultés ils ont tout perdu et a
vraiment urgence à ce qu'on puisse
intervenir à naître par rapport à notre
nation lé mali et pour qui l'état c'est
à dire hors pc exprimé sa solidarité et
son soutien sa compassion avec ces
populations là
dans les moments difficiles qu'on doit
ses souliers c'est donner la main et 26
allemands regardez tout cela madame
développe
toujours au mali une nouvelle vidéo de
notre confrère olivier dubois qui
circule sur les réseaux sociaux en ligne
depuis dimanche elle montre le
journaliste de 47 en otages d'un groupe
qui à dix depuis près d'un an qui
s'adresse à ses proches et au
gouvernement français
cette vidéo d'une minute n'a pas été
authentifiées ni le lieu ni la date à
laquelle elle a été à tournai ne sont
connus cela fait trois cent quarante
jours qu olivier dubois est otage au
mali
on en vient au bilan de l'accident de
train dans katanga en république
démocratique du congo il s'alourdit le
déraillement d'un train de marchandises
ce week end dans le territoire de lubudi
a fait 75 morts la locomotive avec une
remorque de 14 wagons transportait plus
de 100 tonnes de fret à destination de
lubumbashi
selon la sncc l'accident a été causé par
la coupure brusque de la traction qui a
entraîné la dérive de la ramée des
wagons dans un ravin
la mise en garde du secrétaire général
de l'onu contre les conséquences
alimentaires de la guerre en ukraine
antonio gutiérrez parle d'un ouragan de
famine qui va s'abattre sur le monde en
raison du blocage de production agricole
en ukraine et en russie
la guerre devrait avoir des
répercussions sur les pays les plus
pauvres pour rappel l'ukraine et la
russie sont de très gros producteur de
blé écouter
cette guerre dépasse largement l'ukraine
il s'agit également d'une attaque contre
les personnes et les pays les plus
vulnérables du monde
45 pays africains et les pays les moins
avancés importe au moins un tiers de
leur raid ukraine ou de réussi 18 de ces
pays en importe au moins 50%
cela comprend des pays comme le burkina
faso l'egypte la république démocratique
du congo le liban la libye la somalie le
soudan et le yémen
nous devons tout faire pour éviter un
ouragan de famine et l'effondrement du
système alimentaire mondial
et justement l'ukraine est le principal
fournisseur en blé de la tunisie le pays
souffre déjà d'une inflation galopante
liées à la crise sanitaire et la proche
du mois de ramadhan entraîné comme
chaque année une nouvelle flambée décrit
le pouvoir d'achat des tunisiens est de
plus en plus affecté que laurent imbert
stecher
défilant dans les rues de la capitale
tunisienne ils brandissent des drapeaux
et des pancartes mais aussi des
baguettes de pain pour dénoncer la
hausse des prix des produits de première
nécessité
chamia
[Musique]
la tunisie fait depuis plusieurs
semaines face à une flambée des prix et
même à des pénuries alimentaires
une hausse en partie due à une
augmentation de la demande à la proche
du ramadan mais surtout aux
répercussions de la guerre en ukraine un
pays qui fournissait la majorité de son
blé à la tunisie alors que l'ombre de la
famine plane sur le pays le président
kaïs sayed s'en est pris la semaine
dernière aux spéculateurs des
commerçants qui l'accusent de stockées
illégalement des réserves de nourriture
mais pour nombre de tunisiens le
gouvernement et le principal responsable
de la crise actuelle
[Musique]
l'orage est malade
et blessé
huit mois après son coup de force du 25
juillet où il s'est accaparé les pleins
pouvoirs kaïs sayed peine à sortir le
pays de la crise accusé par l'opposition
de faire cavalier seul le président
risque de se retrouver encore plus isolé
s'il ne parvient pas à pallier la
pénurie actuelle
dans la zone l'actualité en bref et en
images les traces de destruction après
le passage du dernier cyclone au
mozambique un cyclone qui a causé de
nombreuses pertes humaines et
matérielles
au moins douze morts 3000 maisons
détruites et 30000 personnes touchées
directement en guinée face à la menace
de manifestations à l'appel de partis
politiques le gouvernement a accepté
l'ouverture d'un cadre de dialogue
depuis ce matin des leaders politiques
sont reçus par les autorités pour
discuter de la transition des partis qui
soupçonne la junte de vouloir se
maintenir au pouvoir et qui dénonce
depuis six mois un manque de dialogue
avec les militaires
cette offensive lancée par l'armée
sénégalaise en casamance une opération
en contre des rebelles moins de deux
mois après la mort de quatre soldats
sénégalais la capture de cet autre dans
la zone frontalière avec la gambie cette
région du sud du sénégal est le théâtre
d'un conflit depuis qui dure depuis
au kenya l'échéance présidentielle
approche à grands pas le scrutin devrait
se tenir en août et le président sortant
ou au kenya officiellement annoncé qu'il
soutenait son ancien rival raila odinga
pour la présidentielle aux kenyans se
passionne pour une élection qui
s'annonce déjà très disputées l'autre
principal candidat actuel vice président
william routot sera lui désigné par son
parti united democratic lines demain
reportage dé nos correspondants bastien
renouil et le dit cousin
arrivée triomphante du candidat raila
odinga
adoubée par le président au kenya tas
[Musique]
c'est la cinquième fois que l'ancien
opposant se présente à l'élection
présidentielle mais cette année l'homme
a réuni derrière lui vingt six parties
au sein de la coalition avignon là où
modja un signe pour certains de victoire
assurée
cette élection est différente d'abord le
président en exercice soutient le chef
de l'opposition lors de l'élection
présidentielle ensuite raila odinga
s'est battu dans l'opposition depuis
1982 jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc ce jour
est venu c'est maintenant
cette alliance met fin à une vie de
rivalités politiques entre uhuru
kenyatta et raila odinga
l'image des deux hommes ensemble est
censé enterrer les divisions d'autrefois
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous voulons montrer notre
unité nous voulons la cimenter afin
d'avancer ensemble politiquement en tant
que coalition asie mios nous voulons
construire notre pays ensemble nous ne
sommes pas inquiets personne ne sera
laissé en retrait
un homme est cependant mis de côté
l'actuel vice président william routot
initialement destiné à succéder au
président ils se vendent désormais
d'être celui qui s'oppose à la dynastie
des qin iata et de fait à raila odinga
une stratégie payante pour ce
spécialiste de la politique kenyane vos
toasts ici
c'est plutôt mauvais la force de route
au ces il a réussi à créer un mouvement
un mouvement national ce n'est pas juste
quelque chose de régionales c'est ce qui
explique que les autres se regroupent
dans un seul camp pour faire face à
cette menace car ou tôt aimer reçue
comme une menace tout fait discrète
selon lui les leaders politiques kényans
sont particulièrement divisée cette
année les élections s'annoncent
extrêmement serrées avec deux principaux
candidats au coude à coude
et on vous reparle de l' empire du
silence le documentaire du réalisateur
belge thierry michel ce film est un
témoignage de ses trente ans passés à
filmer le congo un pays meurtri par
plusieurs guerres un pays qui compte des
millions de victimes les auteurs de
crimes sont aussi nombreux des
mouvements rebelles mais aussi des armes
et celle du congo et des pays voisins 1
aujourd'hui les victimes souhaitent
mettre fin à l'impunité leur message est
porté par ce film est aussi relayée par
le docteur mukwege et prix nobel de la
paix il a mis en place avec l'onu un
fonds pour aider les victimes en
détresse notre journaliste kapinga
sephora lukoki la rencontrer lors de
l'avant première du film ce week end à
paris écoutez
il faut absolument et que la société
civile puissent pousser pour que le
gouvernement puisse ces données le moyen
de pouvoir résoudre cette question il ya
de milliers de victimes par exemple des
violences sexuelles et je pense que si à
la volonté politique les moyens on peut
les trouver un constat amer que lorsque
les victimes doivent attendre 10 25 ans
avant d'avoir la réparation beaucoup
meurent avant même qu'ils aient cette
réparation le but de ces fonds au
mondial pour pour les survivantes c'est
vraiment pouvoir faire cette réparation
intérimaire pour toutes les femmes
victimes de violences sexuelles qui
permet au moins aux victimes si un jour
la justice aura lieu de pouvoir se
présenter devant le juge jean
en toute dignité notre jeunesse c'est
notre force je crois que c'est jeunesse
ne doit pas se décourager il faut savoir
que ça fait puis des vingt ans que nous
faisons le plaidoyer pour essayer
d'arrêter les autres cités dans notre
pays je crois que
la chaire à jamais je dois tout
simplement encourager cette jeunesse de
continuer à se battre et je crois que la
justice un jour poids se mettre en place
pour mettre fin j'espère bien à toutes
ces atrocités qui nous subissons à l'est
du coup
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena et merci à nos correspondants
sans qui ce journal ne pourrait pas se
faire à très vite
[Musique]